Netflix is constantly churning out high
quality entertainment but there's so
much of it in the works that it can be
hard to keep track of what's ahead here
are some of the most intriguing upcoming
Netflix originals to get pumped about
after decades of delighting the world
with his manic Muppets Jim Henson and
his progressive partners in puppetry
released the dazzling and ambitious the
Dark Crystal in 1982 this serious
hardcore fantasy epic with shades of
Tolkien focused on mythical races vying
for control of a powerful gem that keeps
order in the universe it was a
box-office hit and cult classic and now
Netflix is revisiting it the Dark
Crystal age of resistance will be a
prequel series set long before the
events of the film relying on old-school
puppetry instead of CGI there's no hard
release date yet but expect the age of
resistance to hit the streaming service
sometime before 2020 the breakout star
of one of the most popular and
critically acclaimed sci-fi TV shows of
all time is making her way back to a
space set series Katee Sackhoff aka
Starbuck from the Battlestar Galactica
reboot has signed on to star in an
upcoming Netflix thriller called another
life in this dark science fiction drama
that sounds like equal parts alien and
the Orville Sackhoff stars as Nico
Breckinridge an astronaut who leads a
crew on a spooky trip to explore the
origins of an important artifact of an
alien civilization another life boasts a
notable pedigree it's produced by Hal
fire entertainment the company that made
Netflix's acclaimed adaptation of
Margaret Atwood's alias grace there's
room enough in the infinite expanse of
Netflix for another show about the
infinite expanse of space like another
life away is a show about astronauts but
this one is much more grounded in
reality based in part on Chris Jones's
2014 Esquire article of the same name
about astronaut scott kelly the drama is
about Emma Green a fictional American
astronaut struggling with leaving her
family behind for her one-year trip into
the wild black yonder get your tissues
ready away is probably going to be a
tearjerker because of the man behind it
it's the co-creation of Jason Katims the
mastermind behind beloved TV weep fest
Friday Night Lights and parent
the King Arthur legends have been a part
of the cultural fabric of England for
well over a thousand years and these
legends get adapted into movies and TV
shows with regularity because people
know and love them and also because
they're squarely in the public domain
legendary graphic novel creator Frank
Miller will publish his own take told
from the point of view of the Lady of
the lake
cursed won't hit bookstores until late
2019 but Netflix has already recognized
the pull of the material and put a
serialized version of the book into
production starring Kathryn Langford
best known for anchoring the services
controversial hit 13 reasons why
visionary filmmaker Guillermo del Toro
is a beloved fixture of the horror
fantasy genre with a filmography that
runs from the dark fable Pan's Labyrinth
to his more recent hit the shape of
water thanks to a deal with Netflix del
Toro will revisit his roots in the scary
filmmaking who so obviously loves with
the success of Netflix's own black
mirror unsettling anthology series are
back in a way not seen since the heyday
of The Twilight Zone in the 60s the
service wants more and more scary
so it's ordered 10 installments of
Guillermo del Toro presents 10 after
midnight according to Variety del Toro
will produce the series while also
curating the stories he wishes to tell
and will personally hire interesting
filmmakers to make those standalone
episodes
he's also slated to write and direct a
few of the episodes himself with shows
such as glow unbreakable kimmy schmitt
and master of none Netflix helped
popularize the notion of single camera
film like comedy series but Netflix is
all things to all people
so it's also explored the classic sitcom
format with the ranch fuller house and
soon no good Nick this three camera
family comedy stars - very familiar
faces Sean Astin and Melissa Joan Hart
they play parents Liz and Ed a
career-oriented mom and goofy dad who
bring into their family a 13 year old
named Nicole only to slowly realize that
she's actually a con artist with
inscrutable goals from wet hot American
summer quoting comedy nerds - devoted
ant-man loving MCU acolytes just about
everybody loves Paul Rudd he starred in
a couple of Netflix original movies man
he set to star in his first series for
the online giant from the mind of former
Daily Show executive producer
Timothy Greenberg and directed by Little
Miss Sunshine duo Jonathan Dayton and
Valerie Faris
Rudd's latest Netflix project is living
with herself Rudd stars as a man for
whom life did not turn out so well and
so he submits to an experimental
self-improvement treatment one problem
his replacement is his newer better self
and that's also his new rival Joe Hill
and Gabrielle Rodriguez's fantasy horror
title lock-and-key is one of the most
popular and well-received comics in
recent memory three siblings move into
the Massachusetts home that's been in
their family for generations where they
find special keys that give them all
magical and superhuman abilities just
two years after its first issue hit
newsstands in 2008 Hollywood got to work
on an adaptation for television and it's
been in the works ever since Hill will
write on the 10 episode series while
Carlton Cuse have lost is on board as
producer and developer scandals Darby
Stanchfield has attached the star
Netflix has blossomed into such an
entertainment juggernaut that it's able
to attract and more than decently
compensates content creators from the
world of traditional television the
latest is prolific writer director
producer Ryan Murphy who helped make FX
into a prestige channel drawing huge
ratings and winning tons of Emmys for
American Horror Story and American crime
story Netflix offered Murphy 300 million
dollars the most lucrative producer
contract in TV history to do whatever he
wants on the streaming platform the
first of what will likely be many Ryan
Murphy's series feels baryon brand
ratchet a prequel series to the classic
film and novel One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest it focuses on Nurse
Ratched the no-nonsense nurse played by
Louise Fletcher in the 1975 movie
version of Ken Kesey's book frequent
Murphy collaborator Sarah Paulson will
take over the role for the series check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel then hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]